- Aye, what's up.
I'm Brandy's brother.
Aye, they hooked y'all up
with Twizzlers, too?
- Oh, hell no!
[voice echoing]
- Damn, my dudes, we higher than
a white girl at an EDM concert.
- Getting light-headed.
[sighs]
I need oxygens.
And a honey bun.
- The FREQ got us up here
with the third-tier groupies.
- Somebody getting
me pregnant tonight.
I don't care if
it is Clipper Darrell.
[hip-hop music]
- You see baby
girl over there?
Yeah, I'ma make a tape
with her.
- We gotta get out of here.
I came to see dunks by LeBron,
not skeets by Ray J.
- Peep, there go three
seats right there.
Let's gank those bitches.
- Come on, man!
Those is reserved
for the physically
unfortunate.
We can't sit there.
- Yeah!
How you gonna talk
your way into that?
- My mom said
we sitting dere.
I took da bus here.
Da driver let me
honk da horn.
It went "beep beep!"
- Here's your
complimentary bibs.
And remember, keep
your drool off the floor
and your dick in your pants.
Enjoy the game.
- This shit don't
feel right, my dudes.
In my souls and everything.
- Yeah, I'm with Grover.
- Damn, y'all acting like
bitch-ass Minnesota housewives.
I'm untouchable.
Check this out.
- Hey, mother--
- Der!
- Oh, it's okay,
little fella.
- See? Y'all still think
my idea was off?
- Yeah.
I think I'ma bounce.
Ooh, shit, Bron Bron's
coming our way.
Oh, my God, he touched me.
I'll never jerk off
with any other hand again.
- Special gifts
for our special guests.
- Ooh.
- Oh, I see you.
- Damn, she thicker
than a Snicker.
See? Y'all still
trying to bounce?
- Shit!
[all cheering]
[sniffs]
Mmm.
[funky music]
♪ ♪
- Hey, kids.
I got something for you.
You get the shorts,
you get the drawers
and uh, don't mind
the light boo boo stain.
- Damn!
You are the king!
- I love you, LeBron.
- What he write?
- "Thanks for keeping
your dick in your pants.
"The other team could've
used you tonight.
"Watch 'Survivor's Remorse' on
Showtime--I mean Starz.
Your pal, LeBron."
- Man, ain't nobody trying
to watch that bullshit.
[all laugh]
- Yeah, that shit sucks!